[Music]
today we cancel a man by the name of dr
ty winters
now what you should know about dr
winters is that he is a very woke doctor
that's important context here he calls
himself a social justice warrior in his
twitter bio and needless to say he lists
his pronouns which are he him by the way
he also includes the hashtag fight with
your privilege hashtag fight with your
privilege
i think what he means is probably fight
against your privilege or fight your
privilege but the phrasing makes it
sound like he's exhorting us to fight
with it meaning
use it like a weapon who might say fight
with your sword like fight with your
privilege use it as a weapon
it sounds like that sounds like what
he's saying which ironically is exactly
what he does
now the rest of his page is littered
with all kinds of woke graffiti he's
also affiliated with something called
the tour for diversity
in summary dr winters is very concerned
with racism and microaggressions and
diversity intolerance and all the things
that you're required to care about these
days
and wouldn't you know
what a strange turn of events recently
dr winters had an interaction with
somebody
who just so happened to reinforce all of
these talking points it's crazy how that
happens it's a pretty pretty common
coincidence the people who spend most
their the most time talking about racism
are usually the ones who happen to
encounter the most absurdly racist
people in real life
only we never see those encounters we
just have to take their word for it
strange how that happens
so the doctor tweeted this on friday
along with a selfie where he appears
wearing a full suit with a badge that
says doctor
the tweet says
walking down the hallway when stopped by
someone
excuse me you're housekeeping right
i replied no but i can try to help you
if you need something the person looks
down at my badge oh you're a doctor
sorry you look like the custodial staff
um
my god i mean i shouldn't be laughing
it's terrible that's right the terrible
racism is out of control
because that obviously is the not at all
subtle point here the other person was
clearly racist and that's why they
assume that a black man must be a
janitor and the tweet quickly went viral
with lots of leftists sharing it and
expressing outrage i mean they were they
were flabbergasted
they knew racism was bad in america but
but it's even worse than they thought
how could white people be so racist that
they'd think that a man in a full suit
at a hospital is part of the custodial
staff just because he's black
well let me clear up the mystery for you
um luckily uh white people are not that
racist because this never happened
they only
the only thing that would make this less
believable
is if he claimed that the person poured
bleach on his head and shouted this is a
maga hospital
nobody is going to his i'll tell you
this no one is going to think that a man
in a full suit and tie at a hospital is
a janitor
that's not the janitorial uniform
have you ever seen a man in a suit push
a mop like have you ever witnessed that
anywhere i never have
is this supposed to go the reverse way
too i wonder could i walk down the
street as a white man
with like no shirt and no shoes and a
ripped pair of jeans covered in mud
and somebody runs up to me and goes
excuse me sir you're a heart surgeon
right come with me quick my dad's having
a heart attack
are these the kinds of assumptions that
dr winters thinks white people make
but as always with these hate hoaxes the
hoaxer accidentally reveals that he has
never been around an actual white racist
in his life
which is good news
because if he had he'd know that even
racist white people are aware that
non-white people are doctors you
couldn't possibly spend any time in a
hospital anywhere in the country without
encountering that reality
it is a very common thing to see
non-white doctors also even the most
racist person in the world wouldn't look
a black guy in the face and say you look
like the custodial staff
no one is saying that
come to think of it nobody would say the
phrase custodial staff in regular
conversation
maybe if you're a doctor and you only
hang out with doctors
that's how you speak
but but no one is saying that i've never
heard a normal person in regular college
refer to the custodial staff
and normal people also don't refer to
janitors at hospitals as housekeeping
these are all things that make sense in
the privileged elitist mind bubble that
dr smellette lives in
speaking of which the really surprising
thing about the smallet case
was just how lazy the hoax was and it's
this is always the case with these
hoaxes
he planned it out
and invested in it financially but he
showed very little attention to detail
especially when it came time to execute
the hoax so for example the police chief
in chicago who at the time the police
chief who arrested smallett was on the
news this weekend talking about one of
the many red flags that tipped him off
this was all a hoax there were a lot of
red flags he goes through but here's
here here's the one that for him was
decisive listen to this well looking
back on it the the part about the news
but what but what really struck us oddly
because i at that time i had been a cop
30 years 31 years
and so i had been in the detective
division working homicides a lot uh back
when i was a sergeant what really struck
us all
was the fact that he got attacked on the
coldest night of the year during the
polar vortex i remember the polar vortex
i was here for a trip yeah the planes
were frozen the pipes were frozen
insanely cold yeah so nobody was out
there were no people walking their dogs
late at night but i tell you one thing
that really tipped us off that there was
a problem
if somebody gets jumped like that and
okay so let me back up a bit he went to
a subway sandwich shop at like two in
the morning to get a sandwich okay
that's fine
he comes back gets attacked in a
hate crime supposed hate crime
and during all this scuffle they poured
uh bleach on him and all of this
when he got up and went into his
apartment building he still had that
subway sandwich with him
that doesn't happen so went through all
that trouble recruited two nigerians
went out in a polar vortex
but didn't think to drop the sandwich
or even to scuff the sandwich up a
little bit to make it look like it had
just been in the middle of a violent
struggle
the sandwich was pristine apparently
this is the nicest sandwich anyone's
ever seen from subway normally all
subway sandwiches look like they just
got jumped so that made this sandwich's
immaculate condition all the stranger
for the police
the point is that the hoaxers don't
bother to attend the details
dr wintersmolet ii
didn't take a few minutes to come up
with some credible lines of dialogue to
put into the mouth of his fictional
antagonist
he just typed this out in a dash and hit
send
fight with your privilege that's exactly
what he's doing just like smollette
just like all the hoaxers
they are so insulated from actual strife
and struggle and certainly from actual
bigotry that they uh they fetishize it
and yet they can't act out these roles
or invent these stories believably
because they've never encountered these
sorts of people that they're inventing
and for that they should be very
grateful but instead their privilege
makes them bitter and weirdly resentful
and this is what it drives them to
which is why i must say that dr ty
winters is just the latest hoaxer
certainly not the last on this show to
be canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated